Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Lucia: 你在找什么
Jake:没有在晃悠
Jake:开工了
Jake:上班了上班了
Jake:拆快递二楼可能得收拾收拾
Jake:今天做狗吗
Lucia: 其实可以做
Lucia: 到底是做狗还是看狗啊
Jake:都可以做
Jake:可以看看狗
Jake:那我们建立一些逻辑吧
Jake:作为一个这个也是爱狗人还是什么人
Jake:建立一些逻辑
Jake:先看狗然后按照狗做狗
Lucia: 建立逻辑是替人
Jake: 替人好
Jake: For people, right.
Katrina:  那就是先小说看一点狗的款式
Katrina: So we'll first look at some dog styles.
Nicous: 什么是做狗
Nicous: What does "making dogs" mean?
Katrina:  然后开始选择
Katrina: Then start choosing.
Nicous: 做狗
Katrina: Then make them.
Katrina:  然后再做
Lucia: 可以我需要一支笔
Lucia:  就是只要只要能只要能画个大概就行
Lucia: As long as we can draw a rough outline, it's fine.
Lucia: 头暂时还不需要过多考虑哦点
Lucia: 哦   点
Lucia: Oh, point.
Tasha: 三阶段就能卡着利息升8级我靠
Tasha: You can level up to 8 in three stages by managing interest, wow.
Lucia: 在我的眼镜突然被拽歪的时候
Lucia: AI会不会以为地震了
Jake: 那可能地震频率过高
Jake: Then maybe the earthquake frequency is too high.
Lucia: 是不是个好问题啊哈哈
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 也没有很经常吧
Jake: 好好
Jake: Okay okay.
Lucia: 我只是刚才突然抓到线了而已
Jake: 那没电了
Jake: Then there's no power.
Lucia: 我需我需要一根笔老板
Jake: 确实和地震
Jake: Indeed, with the earthquake.
Jake: 什么笔
Jake: What kind of pen?
Lucia: 随便什么笔
Lucia: 能在纸箱上面画出来线就行
Jake: 噢
Jake: Oh.
也来不了i:S：哎我们之前买的彩笔是
Lucia: 好我们已经实现无纸化工作了
Lucia: 现在没有笔是吧
Shure: 哈哈是的
Jake: 是没到是吧
Jake: They haven't arrived yet, right?
Shure: 我们要不要臆想出来一只纸狗
Shure: Should we just imagine a paper dog?
Lucia: 因为我害怕一直用这白板笔
Lucia: Because I'm afraid of using this whiteboard pen too much.
Lucia: 给他用没墨了
Lucia: It'll run out of ink.
Jake: 嗯买买买
Jake: Hmm, buy, buy, buy.
Jake: 所以没到还是还是怎么回事
Jake: So it hasn't arrived yet, or what's going on?
Jake: 之前买的这个
Jake: The one we bought before.
Lucia: 什么没到
Lucia: What hasn't arrived?
Lucia:笔吗
Lucia: The pens?
Jake:笔
Jake: The pens.
Katrina:  彩笔刚到
Katrina: The colored pens just arrived.
Jake: 彩笔
Jake: The colored pens.
Katrina: 刚到刚到菜鸟驿站
Katrina: Just arrived at the Cainiao station.
Jake: 哦那就还能领是吧
Jake: Oh, so we can still pick them up?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake: 今天还能
Jake: We can get them today?
Jake: 今天就能拿到了
Jake: We can get them today.
Jake: 催他们一下
Jake: Push them to hurry up.
Lucia: 雨轩有那种普通的写字的笔
Lucia: Yuxuan has that kind of normal writing pen.
Lucia: 但是我感觉往完了纸上可能有点
Lucia: But I feel like it might be a bit...
Lucia: 有点细做标记的话所以
Lucia: A bit fine for making marks on the paper, so...
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 那就去取快递
Jake: Then let's go get the package.
Tasha: 他虽然能上7个人
Tasha: Even though it can fit 7 people,
Tasha: 但是的卡牌里面的那个概率还是那个
Tasha: The probability in the card set is still that...
Tasha: 那个等级概率啊
Tasha: That level of probability, yeah.
Jake: 走把二楼给收拾收拾给你们跳舞用
Jake: Let's go clean up the second floor so you can dance there.
Shure:  二楼有什么
Shure: What's on the second floor?
Jake: 二楼有饺子
Jake: There are dumplings on the second floor.
Shure:  中午吃的饭还没熟呢
Shure: The lunch isn't even ready yet.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 找点事做
Jake: Let's find something to do.
Tasha: 哎呀你这个连胜没吃到呀
Lucia: 我决定也来压压花吧
Lucia: 这个怎么做呀
Lucia: 稍等这个是不是暂时还用不到
Lucia: 我先放起来
Lucia: 我们需要用到的是哪些呀
Katrina: 这个一套
Katrina: 下面是海绵
Katrina:  然后垫一层这个然后垫一层纸
Katrina: 中间放一层然后就跟汉堡包一样
Katrina: 垫一层这个
Katrina:  垫一层这个
Katrina: 可以看到吧
Lucia:  我看看
Katrina: 然后把它包起来
Katrina: 然后这种花可以上网看一下
Katrina: 有的人建议是摸花瓣
Katrina: 像这种小花就可以直接压
Katrina: 大花的话像压出来效果不好
Katrina: 我这次打算把它这样侧着压
Katrina: 看会不会好一点
Katrina: 我上次这样压
Katrina: 你知道这样压啊
Lucia: 对中间这个就比他们高很多
Katrina: 芍药的话我是
Lucia: Excuse me
Katrina: 因为他这太立体了压不了
Katrina: 我就扒了外面的粉色大片
Lucia: 或者
Lucia: 能不能把这里给他修剪的更短一些
Katrina: 也可以把
Katrina: 压这一块
Katrina: 你可以看网上的教程
Katrina: 反正我也不太熟
Lucia: 没事这个是怎么放的
Lucia: 看看你的
Katrina: 最下面一层海绵
Lucia: 这样子先这个对吧
Lucia: 然后放一层海绵
Katrina: 干燥板放一层干燥板
Lucia: 干燥板这个白的东西
Lucia: 这里面好像没有唉
Lucia: 所以在哪呢
Lucia: 哦对在那里
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: 放纸然后就可以放花了啊
Lucia: 所以就是这里面可以垫好几层海绵
Lucia: 放好几层花
Lucia: 这张有点有点折的
Lucia: 都有点折了
Lucia: 就这样吧
Lucia: 这些给他扔
Jake:活狗可以看一看
Jake: You can take a look at the live dog.
Jake:咖啡店我我没去过
Jake: I've never been to the coffee shop.
Jake:据说200米很近
Jake: They say it's only 200 meters away.
Lucia:我们可以先用自己的理念构思一只狗
Lucia: We can first conceptualize a dog with our own ideas.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake:然后看画的狗和真正的狗长不长
Jake: Then see if the drawn dog looks like a real dog.
Jake:像不像
Jake: See if it resembles it.
Lucia:马非马
Lucia: A horse or not?
Jake:走我们把二楼收拾收拾
Jake: Let's go and tidy up the second floor.
Jake:没没事的兄弟姐妹们
Jake: It's okay, brothers and sisters.
Tasha:啊可以
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Lucia:啊啊啊这这朵枯萎了哦
Lucia: Ah, ah, ah, this flower withered.
Lucia:好消息是我的芍药开始想开了
Lucia: The good news is my peony is starting to bloom.
Lucia:逐渐想开
Lucia: Gradually blooming.
Lucia:文本压那一朵呢
Lucia: What's with that one?
Lucia:绑在外面了
Lucia: Tied it outside.
Lucia:我又把我手机放哪了
Lucia: Where did I put my phone again?
Lucia:哦在这
Lucia: Oh, here it is.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 所以那个衣服怎么说来着
Katrina: So, what's the deal with those clothes?
Katrina: 衣服
Katrina: The clothes.
Tasha:说是租吧
Tasha: They said we could rent them.
Tasha:清一下也可以
Tasha: Or we can clean them.
Katrina: 那线上要下单不
Katrina: Should we order online?
Tasha:我看了一家了
Tasha: I found a place already.
Katrina: 请你发群里吧
Katrina: Please share it in the group.
Katrina: 能让大家报一下尺码
Katrina: So everyone can report their sizes.
Lucia:这花是它
Lucia: This flower, it's...
Lucia:准备谢了还是它没没开
Lucia: Is it about to wilt or it hasn't bloomed?
Katrina: 应该快要谢了
Katrina: It's probably about to wilt.
Katrina: 不然它边边上都那个
Katrina: Or else the edges wouldn't be like that.
Lucia:但它里面就是里面的花瓣有好硬
Lucia: But inside, the petals are really hard.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia:要不这个吧
Lucia: How about this one?
Lucia:这个花形
Lucia: This flower shape.
Lucia:哈哈哈圆一点
Lucia: Hahaha, a bit rounder.
Nicous: 这你都能输啊
Nicous: How could you lose at this?
Tasha:我打的是连败啊
Tasha: I'm on a losing streak.
Tasha:你看我五级星3尊者
Tasha: Look, I'm level 5, star 3 lord.
Tasha:一回合可以吃10个金币
Tasha: I can earn 10 gold coins in one round.
Nicous: 五级星被你搞基了
Nicous: The five-star got messed up by you.
Jake:靠我也五级星
Jake: Damn, I also got a five-star.
Tasha:你看你强度怎么上这么高
Tasha: Look at how high your strength is.
Nicous: 我搞个够吧
Nicous: I did it enough, right?
Nicous: 我就五级星
Nicous: I just got a five-star.
Tasha:哎你猜一个一一一
Tasha: Hey, guess a one-one-one.
Lucia:这
Lucia: This...
Tasha:才从一开始
Tasha: From the very beginning.
Tasha:有什么好伤心的
Tasha: What's there to be sad about?
Tasha:就相当于是一个装备拆卸器
Tasha: It's basically an equipment disassembler.
Tasha:你把它放到备战席上
Tasha: Put it on the bench.
Tasha:他装备就掉下来了
Tasha: The equipment will fall off.
Tasha:没有啊你97滴血
Tasha: No, you have 97 HP.
Tasha:你转啥都行啊
Tasha: You can switch to anything.
Tasha:你可以先先用五极星玩个三连
Tasha: You can play a three-streak with five-stars first.
Tasha:玩到你看你这不是还要几个回合
Tasha: Play until you see, you still need a few more rounds.
Tasha:还要五个回合才能收菜嘛
Tasha: You need five more rounds to harvest.
Tasha:你收了一波菜之后你再转嘛
Tasha: After harvesting, you can switch.
Tasha:转啥都行
Tasha: You can switch to anything.
Tasha:不就是我吗
Tasha: Isn't it just me?
Tasha:还有第二
Tasha: And the second one.
Tasha:赛娜
Tasha: Senna.
Tasha:你多少级了
Tasha: What level are you?
Tasha:玩赛娜
Tasha: Playing Senna.
Tasha:好吧 6级可以玩
Tasha: Okay, level 6 is fine.
Tasha:哎呦这人傻逼吧
Tasha: Oh, this person is an idiot.
Tasha:为什么他打不过我呀
Tasha: Why can't he beat me?
Jake:听说你把心如干蒙了
Jake: I heard you messed up Xinru.
Tasha:是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake:你你现在是第几
Jake: What rank are you now?
Tasha:我现在是这个名字
Tasha: I'm using this name now.
Tasha:但是其实我只是一直在打连败的
Tasha: But actually, I've been losing streaks all the time.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:心如现在还是短暂的第一名是吧
Jake: So Xinru is temporarily first place, right?
Tasha:是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:但是你还是把他打蒙了
Jake: But you still messed him up.
Tasha:他也想连败的
Tasha: He also wants to lose streaks.
Lucia:他浅浅的破防了
Lucia: He got slightly broken.
Tasha:他想要连败
Tasha: He wants to lose streaks.
Tasha:我也想要连败
Tasha: I want to keep losing too.
Tasha:但他连败不过我
Tasha: But he can't lose more than me.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:笑笑死我了
Jake: That's so funny, I'm dying.
Jake:这个很难解释
Jake: This is hard to explain.
Jake:不知道怎么怎么解释
Jake: I don't know how to explain it.
Lucia:好难啊
Lucia: So difficult.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 看下小红书教程吧
Katrina: Let's check out a tutorial on Little Red Book.
Katrina: 我也是瞎做
Katrina: I'm just doing it blindly too.
Lucia:看了但是感觉就这种厚的花
Lucia: I looked, but it feels like the thick flowers...
Lucia:就是很容易会缩
Lucia: They just shrink easily.
Lucia:我在想你有什么办法让它不缩
Lucia: Do you have any way to prevent them from shrinking?
Katrina: 那你就可以压这种小花这样一放
Katrina: You can press the small flowers like this.
Lucia:对对那种小花好压一下
Lucia: Yes, those small flowers can be pressed.
Lucia:但我这个小的感觉它现在开的很旺盛
Lucia: But my small ones are blooming so well now.
Lucia:我有点舍不得把它剪下来
Lucia: I feel a bit reluctant to cut them.
Jake:剪一半
Jake: Cut half of them.
Lucia:还可以这样
Lucia: You can do that?
Lucia:那剩下可以是可以啊
Lucia: Then what's left is okay, but...
Lucia:但那剩下的一半就会很孤单
Lucia: The remaining half will be lonely.
Katrina: 但我这卖不出去啊
Katrina: But I can't sell this.
Lucia:没事我们又不用真货币
Lucia: It's okay, we don't use real money.
Lucia:而且
Lucia: And...
Lucia:你接下来这个肯定会做的非常成功的
Lucia: Your next one will definitely be very successful.
Lucia:第一次那个只是试验品
Lucia: The first one was just a trial.
Jake:哎对齐一下不
Jake: Hey, shall we align it?
Katrina: 你买那个钟
Katrina: You buy that clock.
Jake:就是每一帧都知道时间对不对
Jake: So, you know the time for each frame, right?
Jake:就是可以测试用
Jake: You can use it for testing.
Jake:其实每一帧都是有时间
Jake: Actually, each frame has a time.
Jake:就是对一下
Jake: Just align it.
Lucia:理论上说拍电影是应该这样的
Lucia: Theoretically, that's how movies are shot.
Lucia:不过我鉴于我们这个不是电影所以
Lucia: But considering this isn't a movie, so...
Jake:哎你看过的对吧
Jake: Hey, you've seen it, right?
Tasha:看过了嗯
Tasha: Yes, I've seen it.
Lucia:我觉得就他吧
Lucia: I think it's him.
Lucia:撕下来
Lucia: Tear it off.
Tasha:我打不过你
Tasha: I can't beat you.
Nicous: 你别又打不过我啦
Nicous: Don't lose to me again.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Nicous: 你刚刚才赢的
Nicous: You just won.
Tasha:你赢不是好吗
Tasha: Isn't it good that you won?
Tasha:你看我打不过你
Tasha: Look, I can't beat you.
Tasha:怎么样
Tasha: How about it?
Jake:你们两个人只能交锋一次是吗
Jake: You two can only face off once, right?
Tasha:哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Nicous: 我草我破防了
Nicous: Damn, I got broken.
Jake:骂游戏了
Jake: Swearing at the game.
Jake:是吧你看
Jake: Right, you see.
Lucia:我说他浅浅的破防哈哈哈
Lucia: I said he got slightly broken, haha.
Nicous: 我靠我服了就是你跟我说
Nicous: Damn, I give up. You're telling me.
Nicous: 撸把撸把就撸把在一起可以玩
Nicous: Just play together, we can play.
Tasha:可以玩
Tasha: We can play.
Nicous: 就玩成这样子了
Nicous: And it turned out like this.
Tasha:哈哈你看你还在第一名呢
Tasha: Haha, you're still in first place.
Tasha:这不是一个好兆头吗
Tasha: Isn't that a good sign?
Nicous: 开玩笑
Nicous: Just kidding.
Nicous: 哇靠 你刚拆我背景 当狗插
Nicous: Wow, you just broke my background. Such a dog move.
Tasha:哎我刚刚也被人破防了一次
Tasha: I also got broken once just now.
Tasha:好吧我到现在才六几名
Tasha: Well, I'm only in the sixties now.
Nicous: 还好 是哪个人
Nicous: It's okay. Who was it?
Nicous: 我给他
Nicous: I'll get him.
Tasha:叫蛰伏他已经走了
Tasha: His name is Dormant, he's already gone.
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn.
Lucia:浅浅的刮抹一下
Lucia: Just a light scrape.
Katrina: 我这一层是厚的
Katrina: Mine is thick.
Katrina: 之前压的花瓣
Katrina: The petals pressed before.
Jake:我也要喝
Jake: I want to drink too.
Katrina: 这一层试验品
Katrina: This layer is a test product.
Lucia:有道理
Lucia: Makes sense.
Tasha:你几级啊你
Tasha: What level are you?
Tasha: 你知道我要上10级了吗马上
Tasha: You know I'm about to reach level 10, right?
Tasha:哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake:上面桌子搬完了吗
Jake: Is the table upstairs moved yet?
Shure: 擦完了
Shure: It's wiped.
Katrina: 狗你得
Katrina: Dog, you need to...
俢硕:狗在咖啡店
Shure: The dog is at the café.
Katrina: 对它还没进行社会化训练
Katrina: Yes, it hasn't had social training yet.
Shure: 对它会咬你
Shure: Yes, it might bite you.
Katrina: 对啊但它没长啥牙
Katrina: Yeah, but it hasn't grown any teeth.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina: 没事两三个月
Katrina: It's okay, just a couple of months.
Katrina: 小编沐浴哥是咖啡色啊
Katrina: The editor's cat is brown.
Lucia:好可爱哦
Lucia: So cute!
Katrina: 是很可爱超可爱
Katrina: Yeah, it's super cute.
Katrina: 是啊但是我忘了是左拐还是右拐
Katrina: Yeah, but I forgot if it's a left turn or a right turn.
Katrina: 哦不对
Katrina: Oh, wait.
Katrina: 好像是我们这
Katrina: I think it's this way.
Katrina: 出来以后
Katrina: After we get out...
Katrina: 反正走
Katrina: Anyway, just go.
Katrina: 那店主很佛系
Katrina: The shop owner is very laid-back.
Tasha:可以
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia:有股营养液味
Lucia: It smells like nutrient solution.
Tasha:别说是我了
Tasha: Don't say it was me.
Katrina: 嗯这花怎么会有黏黏的东西
Katrina: Hmm, why is there something sticky on this flower?
Katrina: 这是还有什么声音
Katrina: And what's that sound?
Katrina: 你可以先学
Katrina: You can learn first.
Tasha:狠狠把他暴打了
Tasha: Beat him up hard.
Tasha:现在开始
Katrina: 他下来了呵
Katrina: 他来了
俢硕:人家不爆杀你嘛
Shure: 随便杀他装备都没上呢
Shure: 略施小计就把你玩的团团转谢彬竹
Shure: 你就是这样被女人玩弄的
Shure: 是不是
Tasha:什么
Katrina: 你最后一天啥活动来着
Katrina: 你怎么不用干活呢
Shure: 我最后一天什么活动
Shure: 我是一个
Katrina: 是每个人都要有个ID啊
Lucia:我想看看这个
俢硕:all nice
Lucia:这个这
Lucia:比如说这层放完剩下再放一层纸是吗
Katrina: 再放一层干燥板
俢硕:我我是建立这个经济体系的人嘛
Shure: 你忘记了吗
Shure: Did you forget?
Katrina: 哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh.
Katrina: 明白了
Katrina: Got it.
Shure: 我的唯一任务就是把货币做出来
Shure: My only task is to create the currency.
Katrina: 货币已经买了
Katrina: The currency has already been bought.
Shure: OK解决解决
Shure: Okay, problem solved.
Shure: 伟大无需多言
Shure: Greatness doesn't need many words.
Jake:落地了是吧
Jake: It's on the ground, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:伟大的构想
Jake: Great idea.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 你知道我国第一个货币叫做什么吗
Shure: Do you know what our country's first currency was called?
Shure: 让我
Shure: Let me...
Shure: 那出出现在哪个哪个朝代
Shure: Which dynasty did it appear in?
Jake:包比比
Jake: Bao Bi Bi.
Tasha:你是什么东西
Tasha: What are you?
Tasha:怎么还在这
Tasha: Why are you still here?
Lucia:哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia:哎我那个干燥板怎么又找不到了
Lucia: Hey, I can't find my drying board again.
Shure: 宋代的骄子
Shure: It was the pride of the Song dynasty.
Shure: 是我国第一个出现的纸币
Shure: It was the first paper currency in our country.
Lucia:放哪去了
Lucia: Where did I put it?
Jake:哪真的呀这是
Jake: Is this for real?
Alice:没见过姣子，见过姣子
Alice: Never seen Jiaozi, seen Jiaozi.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Lucia:奇怪
Lucia: Weird.
Shure: 需要帮忙吗
Shure: Need any help?
Katrina: 还有一个板你想做也可以做
Katrina: There's another board if you want to make it.
Lucia:在这边吗
Lucia: Is it over here?
Katrina: 什么你要板吗
Katrina: What, you want a board?
Lucia:对刚才
Lucia: Yes, earlier.
Katrina: 来吧用掉吧
Katrina: Go ahead, use it.
Lucia:啊谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks.
Lucia:明明记得刚才在这边有
Lucia: I remember it was over here earlier.
Lucia:但是这样吧找不到了
Lucia: But now I can't find it.
Katrina: 夹汉堡包
Katrina: Grilled burger.
Tasha:我觉得利桑卓在这个版本最厉害
Tasha: I think Lissandra is the strongest in this version.
Lucia:我觉得这有点厚
Lucia: I think this is a bit thick.
Tasha:5费卡里面
Tasha: Among the 5-cost cards.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha:那刀妹和猴子的话就猴子厉害点吧
Tasha:嗯
Lucia:哎呦太厚了
Lucia:太厚了的话我改变一下策略
Tasha:就抢个无敌2把
Tasha:这把我追
Nicous: 我草
Tasha:我靠你到底要什么你说嘛
Nicous: 我都 可以
Tasha:你可以拿第二的
Tasha:我可以把第二的位置让给你牌给你
Tasha:哦
Shure: 你等他快三星5费的时候你就点了
Jake:谢彬竹还能拿个第二啊
Jake:这么牛逼
Shure: 说实话
Shure: 其实其他6个应该都是人机
Jake:哈哈哈
Tasha:所以输不过他们
Tasha:你知道吗
Jake:哦人机很牛逼
Shure: 不是所以他一个人类都没有几百
Shure: No, so he doesn't have even a few hundred humans.
Shure: 他就是人类中的倒数第一
Shure: He's like the last among humans.
Shure: 我们这左侧的这个RGB是干嘛的
Shure: What's the RGB on the left for?
Jake:你说这个灯吗
Jake: You mean this light?
Jake:它就是光
Jake: It's just light.
Tasha:就打我
Tasha: Just hit me.
Jake:然后分光了
Jake: And then it splits the light.
Jake:它就是白光
Jake: It's white light.
Jake:然后它往这边它就它就分了
Jake: Then it goes this way and it splits.
Jake:它就是分了
Jake: It just splits.
Tasha:我谁都打得过
Tasha: I can beat anyone.
Tasha:不你为什么不往第二名
Tasha: No, why don't you aim for second place?
Nicous: 第一第二和第三有什么区别
Nicous: What's the difference between first, second, and third?
Tasha:哈哈干嘛呀
Tasha: Haha, what are you doing?
Lucia:哎呀妈呀
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Tasha:1只两只3只5只
Tasha: 1, 2, 3, 5...
Tasha:这个还差4只
Tasha: This still needs 4 more.
Shure: 这个什么都想追
Shure: You want to chase everything.
Shure: 你好贪啊
Shure: You're so greedy.
Shure: 你什么东西
Shure: What are you doing?
Tasha:这个不追了
Tasha: Let's not chase this one.
Tasha:就追你们几吧
Tasha: Just chase you guys.
Tasha:这个不追了
Tasha: Let's not chase this one.
Tasha:你你要一下
Tasha: You need to do it.
Tasha:你也不要了
Tasha: You don't need it either.
Tasha:会有几个了
Tasha: How many do we need?
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha:还差两个会
Tasha: Still need two more.
Tasha:还差几个
Tasha: How many more?
Nicous: 你要会是吧
Nicous: Do you need one?
Tasha:会还差两个
Tasha: Still need two more.
Nicous: 我刚刷到一个现在两个
Nicous: I just found one, now we need two.
Lucia:good
Lucia: Good.
Tasha:无敌2 无敌2
Tasha: Invincible 2, Invincible 2.
Tasha:还差3个会
Tasha: Still need 3 more.
Tasha:还差两个
Tasha: Still need two.
Tasha:哎三星乌迪尔了
Tasha: Ah, three-star Udyr.
Nicous: 谁啊
Nicous: Who?
Tasha:就这样我等等呀
Tasha: Just like that, I'll wait.
Shure: 没有那个是镜像过来的
Shure: No, that's mirrored.
Tasha:真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 你不给他装这个了吗
Shure: You didn't equip him with this?
Tasha:哎呦我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha:不是我装的
Tasha: I didn't equip it.
Tasha:这是神器变的
Tasha: It's transformed by the artifact.
Shure: what's this
Shure: What's this?
Shure: bomb has been planted是吧
Shure: Bomb has been planted, right?
Shure: 炸弹已经安放
Shure: Bomb has been planted.
Jake:我靠这东西还能搞闹钟
Jake: Oh my god, this thing can even set an alarm.
Lucia:哎呀妈呀
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Tasha:我刚不是差两张吗
Tasha: Didn't I just need two more?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Tasha:我把一只两星的卖了
Tasha: I sold a two-star one.
Tasha:在干嘛哈哈哈
Tasha: What are you doing, hahaha.
Nicous: 都帮你卖了就这么对我啊
Nicous: I helped you sell it, and this is how you treat me?
Shure: 教教我这个怎么做
Shure: Teach me how to do this.
Katrina: 这就是汉堡包
Katrina: This is a hamburger.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Katrina: 是的
Katrina: Yes.
俢硕:夹花
Shure: Mixed
Katrina: 做狗谁不会
Katrina: Who doesn't know how to be a dog?
Shure: 他说他习惯了做狗
Shure: He said he's used to being a dog.
Katrina: 做狗谁不会
Katrina: Who doesn't know how to be a dog?
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia:做狗谁不会哈哈哈
Lucia: Who doesn't know how to be a dog? Hahaha
Tasha:真的3星了
Tasha: Really, 3 stars now.
Nicous: 而你是我真正的
Nicous: And you are truly my...
Tasha:好这个感觉金铲铲
Tasha: Alright, this feels like Golden Spatula.
Tasha:就是比云顶容易追出来啊
Tasha: It's easier to pursue than in TFT.
Lucia:再来一片
Lucia: One more piece.
Tasha:哎呀刚刚把装备人全卖了
Tasha: Ah, I just sold all the equipped people.
Tasha:现在搞一搞
Tasha: Now let's mess around a bit.
Lucia:太鼓了
Lucia: So loud.
Tasha:他怎么上不上去装备了
Tasha: Why isn't he equipping?
Nicous: 靠你上你给的是那个哎
Nicous: You equip it, you gave that...